what makes you nervous about crypto
right now in terms of
the
regulatory environment or tax treatment
are there any red flags or things that
you've identified that there could be
more clarity on and that you hope to see
more clarity on from either regulators
or accounting best practices and there's
an accounting group that sets the
like the gap standards and all that
stuff have they started putting out
crypto best practices yet they have yet
the aicpa has given out some guidance
some of the stuff that we could talk
about is like some basic accounting like
if you have a bunch of crypto on your
balance sheet and it goes down the
guidance from those groups is to write
it down this is when crypto is not your
business this is like the people who are
paid in crypto or speculating on a cash
management perspective
uh and then the guidance it doesn't make
a ton of sense but it's an intangible
asset so they do they want you to take
the right down but they don't want you
to write it up which doesn't make a ton
of sense to me but that is the i think
the most conservative accounting
guidance they're giving that's different
again than if crypto is your business if
crypto is your business you are writing
it up writing it down that is you know
all taxable so i buy i have 10 million
in my bank account i decide i'm going to
put 1 million of my treasury into
bitcoin it goes down 50
i decide this year i'm going to take
that loss 500 000 i had a profit of 500
000 i'm going to try to not pay taxes
that year correct exactly and we can you
can tesla actually does this right tesla
bought a bunch of crypto they did very
well for a while and then it went down
and so they you can actually read their
financial statements it's just a loss
yeah exactly exactly
so this is a good lesson
for startups in that like crypto does go
down like we're in this huge wave right
now and the fundraising climate is so
frothy that companies that may be
raising 5 million or 10 million before
raising 20 million and sometimes they're
looking around saying like what should i
do with my money so probably my biggest
thing i'm worried about
is companies not having a good cash
management plan something that's board
approved
speculating a little too much or
reaching for yield and some of the
dowels and things like that and then
armageddon
yeah but you know what i'm talking about
right and all of a sudden no i mean i
had this recently i had a company that
raised you know
a large large large large round like
mega round that you're reading about
unicorn size round and
first time founder and what am i
supposed to do with this you know
tens of millions of dollars
and i was like your job is not to
speculate you can put it into short-term
treasuries bonds
maybe
some of them can go into revenue-backed
municipal bonds you know ten percent of
them they might give you four percent
versus
whatever you're getting in treasuries
but our job is to grow revenues
2x year over year that'll dwarf this
that's not our business that that's the
correct discussion right i guess
absolutely correct and i'm going to cut
that out and send that because i get
that question at least once a week
you're not my money fiduciary you are
not you know people are not investing
your company to speculate on
cryptocurrency so be super careful i
know it's tempting especially like
inflation's starting to tick up so
people get kind of nervous and they they
feel like they need to do something it's
just not you're it's not why you were
given the money you were given the money
by venture capitals who were given the
money by
uh foundations and retirement
associations endowments and high net
worth individuals who are doing that in
the other part of the portfolio of which
you are five to fifteen percent of their
overall mix they don't want you mixing
it up in that five to fifteen percent
they want you focus a thousand percent
on that which you told them you would do
which is grow a high growth company
period end of story they have exposure
to crypto they have exposure to equities
they don't need more